or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans s'enflammer
rue du rec ce sens
ensemble les istréens 16 heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pas convaincant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
c'est mon cas
je laime quai suffren tu tichy retouches
content pour mercy contente de moi c'est
bon c'est chez toi ici
avec 12 lots 6 très fort ouais je
suis au concert en concert le
24 juin la promo
dôme de marseille le 24 juin prochain
fois les voir nasa c'est qu'il reste
très très très très peu de places pour
aller voir ma parce que c'est la folie
mais allez le voir c'est monstrueux
c'est le son il sait que je l'aimais
[Applaudissements]
comment gère-t-on brasse gâteau web
bagages et on m'a dit tu passes un
gros bisou ok il y aura qu il ya qui
alonso 6
600 mah sport un calife
dakar est criminel yaris
voilà je crois j'ai fait le tour
c'est le 24 juin au dôme de marseille
s'arrête la folie je sais ma franchement
vraiment pas le prochain 24 juin c'est
le lendemain du 23
e chauffer frérot parce que chaque fou
de toi est vraiment voilà vous avez fait
de me chauffe et je te fais des normes
iso mersen fort et bravo
[Applaudissements]
on s'attend donc à voir
tu attends
je crois qu'un cadeau j'ai même pas des
mecs
avec
mercy venez les fronts
ouais c'est lui
m
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas lire ce chiffre-là mois
les feuilles bon choix il est hélas on
me dit non mais celui-là il est un coin
de table a sorti la tenue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ferrand
me poser dans le salon
[Applaudissements]
thériault
allez pas me casser un
[Musique]
nom si vous ratez la toute fin je
voulais passer par des moments assez mal
[Applaudissements]
dans ma vie
et l'autre là dans du lait de dollars
j'ai d'ailleurs gardé hier que c'est
très bien que chez nous ferait rigoler
bien que celle où il ya que chez nous
soit est de la merde